The following is a production of Frank Defratus and the Internet Red Ziel of Holography.
Hello everyone, this is Frank Defratis.
It's eleven o'clock on Thursday night, and we're live on the World Wide Web.
Hello, everyone.
How are you?
Uh we're going to be showing the Kennedy assassination test bullets tonight.
This is a project that I'm working on doing holograms for uh Jerry Robertson, who has uh put out a work called Denial the Truth Behind the Assassination of President John F.
Kennedy.
And uh we're going to see uh live in just a few minutes what these bullets look like.
Uh one is a pristine bullet.
Uh looks like it has never been fired from a rifle, and it is very similar to the one that's in the National Archives that supposedly did all the damage to uh Kennedy and Governor John Connolly.
And the other bullet is a bullet that was taken and fired into the cadaver's wrist uh just to show what type of damage would happen just from going through a wrist because the other bullet, the pristine bullet, actually went through Kennedy's neck, exited his neck, continued on in the limousine uh to hit Governor Connolly in the back, puncturing his lung, exiting the front of his chest, hitting him in the wrist, shattering all the bones and the rest of them passing through the wrist and embedding itself into his thigh.
And after all that damage, the pristine bullet supposedly was found on Governor Connolly's stretcher.
It worked its way out of his thigh.
And yet we see this other bullet where the only thing that it did was fired into a cadaver's wrist, and you should see the damage of that, and we're just gonna see it in a few seconds uh here on the show.
Eleven ten and eleven twenty.
Excuse me, I'm gonna put these images up.
Next week, we've got something interesting.
If you've ever wanted to know what a hologram is exactly, tune in to the uh wet live webcam next Thursday night, the twenty eighth at 11 p.m.
And I'm going to take several holograms and put them under a high power microscope and broadcast those live images on the world wide web for you to see exactly on a microscopic level what makes up a holographic image.
Because as you know, if you pick up a hologram and hold it in the light, uh you see a three-dimensional image.
But if you take that hologram and just look through it, if it's not in a frame or anything, it's just like a clear piece of glass, just like the glass that's in your window of your home that you can see right through.
Only when the light hits that hologram at a certain angle does the holographic image appear.
And there are actually uh fringes, interference patterns that make up this uh holographic image on a microscopic scale.
So we're going to take the webcam, attach it to the microscope, and during the show we're going to put several holograms under the microscope, and you'll be able to see what makes up a holographic image on the microscopic scale.
I've taken a look at it already.
It's fairly interesting.
It's uh something you may want to tune in to see.
Our special guest this week is Dr.
John Perry from holographics north in Burlington, Vermont.
And if you've ever wondered what it would be like to create large holograms, and large by large I mean three and a half by six feet in size, and working on a table that's twelve feet wide by twenty-two feet long.
In fact, this table is so big that they walk around on the table to set up the optics.
They just get right on the table and walk around on it.
So uh he's going to fill us in on what it's like to work at that end of holography, one of the large uh format holograms.
And he's coming up in just a moment.
I've got another guest in the studio with me right now.
It's a special guest as well.
It's my daughter Faith.
Faith, how are you tonight?
I'm okay.
How are you doing?
Okay, we just got Faith back from college her first year.
And Faith is uh majoring in physics with a minor in Mathematics.
Mathematics.
How did the first year go?
It was a lot of fun.
Are you telling the truth?
Yes I am.
It was fun.
It was difficult, but it's very rewarding.
Now what do you hope to do with a major in physics?
Well, after I finish uh undergraduate school, I'd like to go to graduate school to get my PhD.
Hopefully in astrophysics and someday work for NASA.
You know John Perry's an astrophysicist at the University of Vermont.
And what did you cover this year?
Did you have any optics?
Towards the end of the semester we had a little bit, but we didn't go into details.
Optics is pretty tough I guess right?
Figuring out uh paths of light and things.
Yeah.
The mathematics behind it.
Yeah, it's harder than regular physics all of the rest of physics.
And uh they'll probably pick that up next year, right?
Next spring they're offering an optics course.
Any lasers and holograms this year?
Not this year.
I'm surprised that they don't uh you know, I I run laser and holography classes for students down as far as third grade, believe it or not.
I'm surprised that uh they wouldn't bring lasers and holograms into a first year physics class if if for no other reason than to uh show the students what cool things can be done using lasers and and the physics behind uh holography itself.
I had your physics professor in one of my classes.
Yeah, I'm aware of that.
Yeah.
Uh my daughter's physics professor was a student in one of my laser holography classes at Lehigh University back in the eighties.
And she found it very, very interesting.
And uh she pursued well, her background's in crystals, right or something.
Yeah.
I also want to congratulate you on your recent appointment to being the president of the Society of Physics Students at the college.
Yeah, our chapter of it.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
So I started uh an astronomy club this year.
We went up to the uh roof of my dorm to look at the stars and uh that was sort of through the society, but I did it on my own.
I got the key from my professor.
We went up there every Wednesday night to look at the stars when it was clear.
It's a lot of fun.
They have a nice telescope up there?
Yeah, they have a few pretty big telescopes.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well, it's good to have you back home.
It's nice to be back home.
Okay, well, I always wanted to get you on the show.
Thank you for being a guest on my show.
Thanks for inviting me to be a guest on your show.
Okay, let's move on.
Well, why don't we start off uh let our listeners know that we're speaking with Dr.
John Perry, who has a company is it still in Burlington, Vermont?
Still in Burlington.
And the company is holographics north.
And I would I'd I'd say it's safe to assume to say that your company's known for large format holography.
That's definitely our specialty.
Okay.
That's right.
Would you tell us a little bit about the holographic services that you offer for your clients?
Sure.
We make display holograms up to sizes uh three and a half by six feet, uh which would be about one point one by one point eight meters.
We make white light transmission.
Uh we do some reflection work, not that big.
Uh-huh.
It's mostly white light transmission work or what we call rainbow work.
Uh a good deal of what we do these days is stereogram holography, which means we can start with uh essentially movie footage.
So we can we can enlarge and reduce images, we can shoot on site, we can shoot in flood lighting instead of laser lighting.
We can animate the subjects.
Uh probably most of the listeners are familiar with stereograms.
We can also work with computer models, and those can be animated, morphed.
Um we can do full color, uh we don't do a lot of it, but we've done some full color.
The uh clientele tends to be trade show, uh corporations doing trade show booths, museums, mostly science-related museums, uh, technology centers, that's a very international market, and artists who have projects that are funded and they come to us pretty much as fabricators uh to to produce the work for them, and often they're in residence here when we do that.
Most of us could probably not even comprehend making a hologram that size.
I'd say that the biggest part of the audience would work with maybe four by five inch plates in their homes and schools.
I would imagine that working with film that size is a little bit like uh working with wallpaper, isn't it?
I wish it was that easy, although wallpaper has its own problems.
Uh of course we're working on film, as you said, and uh holding the film has its own peculiar problems.
But probably the worst part, the most difficult part of large format is that although the uh uh the difficulties in stabilizing all the optical elements and stabilizing the film, that the difficulty of doing that increases probably with the area of the film, I would say.
So we're we're probably a hundred times uh something like that more difficult than an eight by ten inch.
The tolerances that were allowed are just the same.
Yeah, we still have to be stable to roughly a millionth of an inch.
Uh so it is extremely difficult.
It's taken many years, really.
It took about a decade to to really feel comfortable with the processes that we use to be able to do that.
And our location is critical.
Uh Burlington, Vermont is not only a great place to live, but it's quiet.
Uh there's there's no train system coming in, the airport's over the hill from us, and um it's a it's a pretty pretty low vibration area that we're in, and we're in a we're in an old brick school building, pretty solid one.
Um residential area of town, and we're in the basement, of course, with nice eleven foot ceilings, it's a really great basement.
And the foundation of this building is three feet of solid stone with about two feet of brick above it.
So it's a it's a great location.
If I remember correctly from a story I read about your company, maybe in Holosphere back in the eighties, I would say.
You actually work on a floor instead of a table, right?
The the floor itself is isolated from vibration.
Did you pour like a large concrete floor or something?
That's right.
We we call it a table, but we step right onto it.
I mean, it's at floor level.
Uh frankly, our landlord at the time insisted on this.
He wouldn't let us pour a concrete slab uh three feet above the floor.
It's twelve by twenty two feet and it's fourteen inches thick.
That's a lot of concrete.
And one of the advantages to floor level is of course you can just step right on it and walk around.
You don't have to climb up and climb down.
We have more s headroom over it of course by doing that also.
But another advantage more practically is that someday if somebody puts that room to other uses, all they have to do is tile the f tile the table, basically, and it's a floor again.
Um the uh concrete has reinforcement in it, it's not steel, it's fiberglass reinforcement.
Um we we basically dug a huge hole um in the ground and uh and filled it up with snow, uh which we have plenty of here, and then poured the concrete on top of the snow and with a little blue board in between to keep the heat of the curing from from melting the snow too fast.
Wow.
And then by the time the snow was melting out, the concrete had had set enough to to support itself.
There are four legs that that that hold the whole thing up.
A fairly complicated structure actually underneath that kind of supports all that concrete.
And that all sits on piers that go down through sleeves, uh fifteen inch diameter sleeves.
They go down about fourteen feet, and then they're anchored directly into the uh glacial till is really what it is, um, deep under the building.
So we don't float and the table is not pneumatically suspended, um, but it's isolated from building vibrations.
We pick up ground vibrations but not building vibrations.
Again, it's a it's a quiet neighborhood.
Now I I can imagine when you have enough distance you can spread a laser li uh laser beam out to uh cover that area of the plate.
But do you use collimation also?
Well yes and no.
Our reference beams uh on transfers and also on shooting masters are not collimated.
Uh they're spreading over lengths of twenty to thirty five feet depending on just what we're doing.
So it's a pretty good long throw.
That's what counts as far as how close you are to collimation is the distance from the from the point source basically from the spatial filter.
Um so that's pretty good.
Uh when we're illuminating masters we do have a one dimensional collimator.
We have a curved mirror a a strip mirror about sixty inches long and curved in that long dimension.
It's curved to about a thirteen and a half foot radius um uh let me correct that 13 and a half foot focal length uh the curve is so we can um well when we illuminate masters we can produce an exact conjugate of the of the reference beam with which the master was shot so we don't get any distortion in the projected image from the master and that's really the important part.
Uh the reference on the transfers is not collimated and of course the illumination beam later is also not collimated and and and cannot copy that but but that's not as critical since the image is is is image plane at that point.
What what are some of your latest projects that you've worked on?
Well we just put six holograms onto the Grand Princess um which if you're not familiar is the biggest cruise ship in the world.
Um I think it's two point two times the size of the Titanic in in volume.
Um it was being built in northern Italy I was over there about a month ago to just check on the lighting specs and those holograms are installed.
Um the ship is sailing but not in not in commercial service yet.
It'll be another couple of weeks.
And I'm getting good feedback.
I'm getting feedback that they are a great attraction.
They're in the casino.
What were the content?
Mostly underwater scenery.
Uh two of them are computer generated.
One was dolphins, um sort of a m mama in a baby dolphin diving down through the water and then arcing back up again as you walk by the hologram and a lot of flora and fauna, starfish and lots of little fish of all kinds sort of floating around and doing their thing.
A lot of seahorses in that one, little tails wiggling and stuff.
It's it's a great image.
It's in two colors, it's six feet wide.
Wow and uh about three feet, three and a half feet tall.
Yeah, it's our maximum size, three and a half by six, and lots of animation, um, which is why the lighting was a concern to be sure we had a good long light path.
Uh the other big one, the other three and a half by six foot hologram, there are two of those, um, is uh sting rays, uh kind of a flock of them, uh uh shall we say flying or floating or swimming out toward you um as you walk by and then there's a lot of fan coral and fish, and there's a big uh shark in the background kind of filling up the middle of the frame, so there's a lot going on in there.
And the third one was not a stereogram, it's a it's a shall we say a traditional hologram of a turtle.
We have a great stuffed turtle here.
Big big sea turtle about three feet long.
Um and uh it's a two-channel, so he moves as you walk by, but in in a sudden one sudden jump, and a lot of flora and fauna in that one too.
So they're they're great.
They're they're just wonderful images.
We're very pleased with them.
So you use that holographic table just about the same way that someone would set something up in a theater at that size.
Uh pretty much.
It's a lot of fun.
I have to walk, you know, ten or fifteen feet just to just to get from one side of the subject to the other sometimes.
Has the IFA situation had an impact on what you're doing yet?
Well um it's had an impact on my banker I guess.
I I've um I've stockpiled about a five year supply of of a large roll film.
And we we have that.
I mean it it was delivered last fall.
Seems to be pretty good quality um and I've got it pretty well uh you know pretty well wrapped up and in in a dehumidified environment.
So that'll last us hopefully until something else comes along.
I think Slavish uh it looks pretty good.
It's slow film, the new film made in with Lithuania appears to be a a pretty good substitute except it's gonna take a lot more energy unless they can do something about that.
What are you using like a uh five or twenty watt argon?
No.
Uh this may surprise you we use a fifty millwatt helium neon.
Oh really like one of the one twenty fives.
That's exactly what we have.
Two of them have edelons retrofitted into them for uh increased coherence and of course we get lots of coherence about fifteen meters so we can shoot deep subjects and um you know we measure our path lengths but we get 'em within three or four feet and don't worry about it and um and those uh we're just we just kind of count our photons one at a time.
I mean we s we save them very carefully and try not to waste light.
And um we've got some pretty fast uh developer uh processes that we use and um we get by pretty well.
Our exposure times tend to run about oh twenty to forty seconds sort of in that range sometimes even less uh even on the big shots.
We get very bright masters.
We get real screaming bright masters.
Those um one twenty five's I think when they're retrofitted and reworked now, they put out about a hundred or seven milliwatts, don't they?
That's right.
Yeah.
With the Edelon tuned properly, we generally get seventy or eighty or even ninety when that tube is fresh.
Some t somewhere in that range.
Yeah.
Yeah, they're they're great lasers.
I mean they're you just turn 'em on and they go.
It's just wonderful.
That's a lot of eggs of film to have in there.
I bet um you could probably take one of those sheets and cut it up into a four by five inch pieces and make a fortune.
These people would pay top price for that right now, I would imagine.
Yeah, not not part of my corporate charter but not really what I'm interested in doing.
Yeah, but that's true.
It is a lot of film and um several artists have bought film and had it sent here for us to to keep in storage for them.
Yeah, you have a few a few lab people that work with you?
Or do you work pretty much alone?
Well, I have one.
There are really just two of us here.
Um that number goes up and down a bit.
You know, last summer uh it was four, um, but it's been two this winter and uh I think really that reflects the streamlining of our processes.
I used to have nine employees, um that was the max about maybe six, seven years ago.
Mm-hmm.
And all the people that have passed through here or working here have just done a great job in helping me streamline all these systems so that basically it could be done by one person.
Now I didn't let them go because of that.
It's the old lay yourself off routine.
Um but they they all really headed on to different you know, different pastures uh for employment on their own pretty much.
And that was a that was a good way to do it.
But um so, you know, the uh for instance the the uh stereogram camera that makes masters from film footage, uh it's it's run by a small desktop computer.
Oh that's pretty automatic.
Um I mean I I just sit down and program it in and it goes.
I know the optics really well.
I know the I know the hardware and the optics and I can I feel very comfortable with that.
If I have to fix it or change it, modify it, the software I do not and the fellow who wrote it is still in town.
I see him a lot.
So is your background master of physics or am I?
That's correct.
Yeah, I still teach astronomy, uh a very no math uh sort of introductory course uh at the university here, University of Vermont.
Mm-hmm.
We get a lot of kids that listen to this show too, because they love holograms.
Especially when you get around eighth grade or so.
And believe it or not, a lot of them would probably like to grow up and do exactly what it is that you're doing.
What would you have to say to them?
Would you advise them to uh look into that or maybe not?
How do you feel about the the industry itself of holography and where you think it's going to be maybe in about ten years or so?
Do you think it's going to be a viable industry that's going to need to be able to do that?
I think that there will be components of it that will continue to grow and be viable in ten years and probably bigger than they are now.
Mm-hmm.
And in particular, uh those would be um the packaging and and counterfeiting or anti counterfeiting areas that I think are still still growing.
Um and uh and interferometry, uh measurement quality, control, testing, uh with with holography is a is a very, very valuable technique.
It's just enormously valuable.
And there are lots and lots of uh spin off technologies and and and improvements uh to those uh basic um uh methods that were there ten or twenty years ago.
Display holography, I would say fine art, it it I think the I think the applications are pretty much limitless.
I think it has a it really can have a great future as a as an art medium.
Mm-hmm.
But for commercial display, which is pretty much what we do, if it's a lot of what we do, um I do think the market is dwindling.
I think it went frankly I'm being very blunt here, I think it went quite a while on uh on uh uh the a novelty appeal.
Mm-hmm.
And it still is a very valuable medium in its own right.
Um but it has to be used properly to to make use of that value and I think um a lot of commercial artists, let's say or designers don't don't see that value.
It's our job to try to show them.
Uh and it's difficult to do that.
It's not cheap.
I mean it's a labor intensive undertaking and it's it's not like having a codachrome slide, you know, duped.
Um tell us a little about your website.
Well um it's uh was updated a little over a year ago I think um my son did it actually is a uh computer science student in college right now and my instructions to him were to keep it uh looking snappy and business like um I didn't want any kind of phony baloney stuff but I wanted I wanted it to look interesting and have a lot of information on it so I think it was exactly what I was looking for.
Um it's at W W W dot Hollow North H O L O N O R T H dot com.
Okay.
And um there's a list of clients on there, a list of museums also collect our work um and uh some examples of your work as well, right?
Yeah, we have a stock image list.
We do have a shelf stock of about about twenty five I think different images right now and there are little black and white pictures of uh of those uh together with descriptions that's on that website and considering the size the price is unbelievable.
Well we size of the whole we hear it both ways some people expect 'em to be fifteen bucks and other people expect them to be uh a hundred and fifty thousand.
It's amazing.
Um there's a lot of mis uh communication or let's say misunderstanding about holography out there.
A lot of people just don't know what it is or they think it's something else really um borrowed from Star Wars maybe.
Why do you think that is?
I mean uh you and I met I don't know if you remember in New York and we tried to hang one of your shows.
I remember well.
Yeah.
And um I mean we've been in this for a long time.
Why are we still at the same point we were in then?
I don't I don't see where we've moved anywhere.
Well in educ in the education of the general public.
Yeah.
I think two things I can point to uh one it is hard to understand.
I think it's difficult to really get a handle on how it works.
And um there are various ways to to to approach that answer to or to answer that question and all of them are um kind of hard to follow.
Um and the other is that a lot of misinformation is being pumped out all the time, mostly in Hollywood, I'd say in movies and T V shows.
And it isn't it isn't even close.
And that confuses people and I I don't blame them.
I think it's very confusing but the kind of basically the the junk that's being put up and called holography.
Holography has a lot of advantages over some of that stuff that's being uh shown in movies and of course it also has some disadvantages um and we suffer from those.
We have a show coming into a center that I'm involved with we opened a science and technology center here in the Lehigh Valley through Lehigh University.
The Discovery Center of Science and Technology we have a traveling exhibit from Pacific Science Center which is coming in for the summer.
Yes.
Called Lasers and holograms.
And you have several holograms in there.
Could you tell us a little bit about what the public can expect to see?
Um I'll I'll if you can remember what they are.
It was a while ago that that show was put together.
Um and so it's sometimes since we since we uh gave them those holograms.
But uh as I recall there are maybe four or five white light transmissions, something uh along those lines.
And I think that our T Rex skull is pretty definitely one of those, the big dinosaur skull life size, and that's that's a great piece.
It's gotten a lot of the manual that was sent out for the exhibit, they have the one where uh the person this I think it's called Burst.
Where the person's blowing a large balloon.
Yes, blow up uh um is is the name of that piece.
And uh yep, it's a woman uh sort of holding a balloon in front of her face, blowing it up, and she's got her two hands on the balloon and her fingers are kind of spread out and then uh it's a two-channel hologram.
When you step to the right, you see the balloon uh having disappeared and you see her face and her hands are still there and um she's still in the in the motions kind of a blowing up this balloon but the balloon is gone.
And you see both images together, they're superimposed on each other.
Oh, I see.
So you see the balloon but you also see her behind it.
And then the first image disappears near the case.
Are they are they is that a pulsed hologram?
No, uh yes, it's pulsed.
Yeah.
Pulse that in Toronto with Michael Soudon.
Um research um back uh about eight or nine years ago, something like that.
Yeah.
It's a it's a nice piece.
It's a great piece.
I think the other one is maybe the Space Telescope and uh I'm just pulling this out of memory here because I don't have a book with me.
Yeah, it could be the Hubble Space Telescope.
We have a hologram of that, and we have a hologram of the uh Freedom Space Station, the US space station, which never got launched, at least not yet.
Um if it does, it won't look like what it looked like back then.
The design.
And we have both of those images in one hologram as a as a two-channel hologram, that might be what they have, I think.
I see.
Well, John, I want to thank you very much for being on the show.
And uh is there anything you want to let the listeners know before you head out?
Probably not.
Just uh check out our website.
I think you'll find it entertaining.
And um, you know, if you have any other uh information you need or interest, give us a call.
Okay, and we have a link to Holographics North website right on the Holo Talk page.
So you just click on that link and off you go.
Great.
Thanks, Frank.
John, thank you very much for being a guest on HoloTalk.
Bye.
Take care.